[Music]
finding the right job can be challenging
enough but now experts are warning
people to be on the lookout for scammers
posing as potential employers the Better
Business Bureau says fraud involving
fake job offers now ranks as the third
riskiest type of scam Americans ever
reported losing more than 2.9 million
dollars so far this year
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn is here to tell us all
about it flat good morning good morning
experts have a warning if the job seems
too good to be true it likely is
employment scams are increasing giving
false hope to people looking for work
preying on those who are often already
struggling to make ends meet we spoke to
one woman who thought her financial
burdens were over when she received what
she thought was a dream job offer only
to be driven deeper into debt it was a
very nice email you know I'm considering
you please respond back tell me a little
bit about yourself where do you want to
see yourself in 3 to 5 years
Kathleen Boylan jumped at the
opportunity after the mother of two had
been searching for work on popular job
sites for months the position offered 90
thousand dollars a year to be the
administrative assistant to a man named
Stephen at a canadian-based company
when you saw that job offer this was a
godsend yeah I already started figuring
out what I was going to do to repair the
house I was behind on tuition payments
for my daughter's school so I was
excited welcome aboard
the next email read you will receive a
mail from FedEx with instructions as
promised Boylan got a check for $3500 in
the mail and directions to deposit it
through mobile ATM or branch which she
did here at her local Wells Fargo over
the next few days
Stephen kept her busy looking up flights
for a potential business trip even
sending this passport photo and when a
company bill needed to be paid he told
Boylan to buy reloadable cash cards so
he could pay it off
she bought 5 $500 cards and sent him the
codes on the back that's when Boylan
says the man she thought was her boss
stopped responding and reality
slowly sunk in you've been swindled yeah
the check was fraudulent Boylan lost
over $3,500 in total funds her bank says
she still owes there was like hope for
like two weeks that I'm gonna get back
on my feet again I'm gonna make things
right my kids gonna be able to not have
to worry about tuition and just to be
financially solvent you know it was just
that hurt job scams like these are on
the rise the Better Business Bureau
found it's the third riskiest scam for
consumers overall with an average of
more than six thousand dollars lost for
each victim
Catherine Hutt is BiBi B's national
spokesperson for all scams they either
want your money or they want your
identity and we've seen both with
employment scams Boylan now drives for a
limousine service and rideshare
companies to make ends meet but says the
money stolen hit her hard
I can't even look to the future it's
just like how do we get to next month in
this case the scammers used a real
company and the photo of an actual
employee so HUD says make sure you
verify by calling the company whilst
Fargo told us security is its top
priority but it doesn't comment on
specific ways it prevents fraud to
ensure its measures are effective the
bank also warns consumers to be aware
that scammers will often ask victims to
deposit bad checks and withdraw the
funds before the check is actually
cleared and your heart just goes out
yeah she's trying to make ends meet
she's got kids in school she can't pay
for their tuition and she's struggling
even in this economy and she says they
took away my future right so this is I
mean whoever did that Stevens we're in
America my guess I think of how many
more people out there like her - all
right glad thank you